on this episode I sneak out of jury duty
to bring you the show
[Music]
[Music]
this is
Gary B hey everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is episode 114 of
the askgaryvee show today was a show
that was not supposed to happen as you
guys know yesterday I mentioned that
today would not happen but it's a little
bit of a curveball this is a very
special jury duty edition of the
askgaryvee show I saw an opening a big
opening they gave us for lunch I emailed
the gang and here we are and I guess
that's that first big love to the
vaynernation so many lurkers came out so
many of you talking about the awesome
energy of episode 113 I agree instant
classic India in my opinion and I guess
we should get into it so India let's get
into the show Jim Gerald as if your kids
want to join the family biz will you
start them at the bottom Gerald if the
kids want to go into the family business
which is really interesting to me I'm
super curious what ends up happening
with Misha and Xander and honestly at
that point as I project 15 to 20 years
out I feel the Empire is gonna be at
such a level that it's gonna be in tamii
crap the family may business in 20 years
may actually be the Jets yes 100 percent
I will actually 1000% make them stop
start from the bottom I'm gonna throw a
curveball and I know little Zander a
little Misha you're watching this right
now probably in five to seven years from
now where you can comprehend this but I
need to see this and I need you to know
your dad is not bullshitting you not
only will I make them start from the
bottom upward let me rephrase I'll make
them start from the appropriate place
that their education or skillset as a
young entrepreneur or executive created
just like I would treat you or d-roc
anybody else but here's the way more
interesting part but I won't let them
ascend to being number one at least
while I'm alive unless they ascend to be
number one I think the thing that I'm
most proud of both in Wine Library and
with vaynermedia is we have friends and
family involved in both businesses and
the levels that people play in are
actually all over the place is something
you guys know
so many of AJ's dear friends are
involved in the company and you know
that there's just different levels we're
not gonna get into names but like people
are playing at different levels and
obviously kids are different and I could
be conceivably completely full of [ __ ]
because I'm not completely quantifying
the enormous amount of love that I'm
going to gather in them over the next
years but I have a funny feeling that my
respect for meritocracy and capitalism
is gonna force me into that game and
number two I'm thrilled to write them a
nice check more than 99% of people
deserve for them to go do their own
thing if they don't like it if you don't
like it standards go do your thing
Misha oh you're mixing it up huh I like
I do rocks mixing it up you better have
kept the gray as we kind of moved all
right
did we get mine did we get my green on
green on green did we get my like give
me the color now I went super like
peppermint pattie
up on 114 so you like this way yeah nice
awesome all right let's go
jinsan asks do you work on your birthday
couple things my man number one I hate
my birthday my fortieth birthday is
coming November 14th of this year that
was a little bit of a specific drop
mainly because I want the entire
vaynernation to buy me a lot of gifts
jets jerseys of random rare players are
at the top of the things that I like
medium I've worked on every birthday of
my entire life
all of them literally even some in my
teenage years cuz they happen to fall
weekends when my dad was dragging my ass
s store but since I became a full time
professional at 22 I've worked every
birthday it's I've given a talk I gave a
speech like the the Remax convention for
Thank You economy came out during my
birthday like gave a speech on my
birthday
yeah absolutely like that doesn't that
was a silly question
100% all in you want to do what you love
on your birthday I'm lucky enough to be
doing what I love Ben asks how do you
handle people missing deadlines they
said I've been the son of Justin kind of
question poorly because usually I
usually I you know look let me break
this down actually the way I struggle
the way I react to people who set their
own deadlines and miss them are
predicated into the a and B bucket that
I put that man meaning either I put you
into a bucket where you're a hardcore
executor you're extremely reliable
you're on your [ __ ] you're you know teas
and eyes and everything and that's what
I value in you because that's what
you're great at if you miss a deadline I
am pissed
cuz that's what you do now if you're in
the magic category GRA stumbling all
over yourself calling out sick randomly
weird but you got magic and you make
stuff happen knowledge I kind of think
you're gonna miss your did I actually
don't even believe you in the first
place when you set a deadline and so
that I'm ok with another two or three
days so I think it predicates completely
on where I have you bucketed and
are you actually executing on that
bucket so that's how I react to that
question
let's move it around oh look at me now I
like that like the city bike stuff all
right
I don't want to get on there like Karen
asks what are your thoughts on 3d
printing technology and the potential to
integrate with social media I'm a big
fan of 3d printing you know I think if
you play it out at scale 3d printing is
one of the most destructive things going
on that I think a lot of people talked
about and it's not the hot topic right
now which makes me feel like in 2019
2020 - it's gonna pop and every zoom
look what it's kind of like the Internet
itself right after the dot-com bubble
burst in a 1 on Wall Street people kind
of didn't realize the Internet was only
growing and would really be a factor
same thing with 3d printing it got a lot
of pizzazz now it's a kind of soft
period everyone's talking about the
Ebers and the Airbnb s I think it's
gonna really rear its head in five to
seven years you know how it integrates
to the social is not interesting I'm not
trying to be disrespectful I don't think
that's interesting I think what's
interesting is if you sell a physical
good between five and a hundred dollars
I think you have real disruption coming
up in five 10 15 20 years like like
nobody's buying a screwdriver in 15
years you're making one and that's
intense and then 3d printing gets into a
real intense place including like people
arguing about gun control in a world
where people gave you printing guns in
their home like who gives a [ __ ] about
gun shows and permits I'm printing it in
my basement so society will evolve we
will always adjust you go show somebody
who lived 150 years ago all the
intensity we deal with they would have
thought that we would have killed
ourselves off by now humans have a funny
way to adjust I mean on team human but
don't get a twist that 3d printing is a
massive disrupter and over the next two
decades will rear its head for all of us
so come back up it sort of warm I kind
of like the shave Clinton asks are you
ever scared before you do something big
anything at all it doesn't even have to
be business-related Clinton the only
thing that I'm scared of really in a
public setting or that might sound big
this is what the askgaryvee show is for
right we've got to show the 360 it's
probably gonna be one of the more
vulnerable things that i've said on the
show and it's I'm setting it up but
you're all gonna be like what I am
actually scared of reading in public
because I'm I'm come to learn in the
last three or four years I'm an
atrocious reader I really struggle with
it as a matter of fact one of the big
shifts in 2015 that I've made is I'm
making a lot more 5 & 7 minute meetings
with my staff because I don't read fast
enough for the value of my time you know
even when I read to Misha
believe it or not I'm like a quarter of
an inch hesitate like if I had to create
the greatest story off the top of my
head right now for Misha I feel cozy and
calm like reading like goodnight moon
among like like I'm just a terrible
reader like and Passover like reading
the things in the table like I don't
like to read it's funny when I started
getting asked to do TV shows one of the
reasons I didn't want to do a TV show
was I didn't want to read off the chyron
and then and even when I did my wine web
radio show on Sirius for nine months my
first commercial read was a disaster
probably the worst thing I ever did
publicly guy came in sam benroubi Big
Ups yeah father of many of the employees
at vaynermedia came in this like do what
Howard Stern does he can't read either
just read it and then do your thing the
second read was insanity because I read
it I knew what the Stella Artois
ironically at vaynermedia client now
what that ad wanted to get off and I did
an incredible read so I'm very improv I
know what I'm good at
I'm stunningly not scared of most things
I'm scared of snakes somewhat of heights
I really am Alta mately scared of dying
and weirdly enough the first thing that
came to mind was I really don't want to
read in public badly like that is
probably like at the top of the list
believe it or not and that's kind of
intriguing to me it's a funny kind of
thing so
that's it that's it huh it was a nice
concise show if you think about kind of
the feedback yesterday I was like that's
a long one fun show I'm really glad I'm
continuing it super excited I saw a
bunch of you saw what I put out on
Instagram I'll go to the official term
tomorrow but I'm gonna do a Kickstarter
like thing probably tomorrow or next day
and so be ready for it where I'm adding
at least 100 to 200 questions to the
askgaryvee book that's coming out early
next year that I've never been answered
before and I'm gonna do some sort of
thing where people that are watching
show if they pre-order I don't know if
I'm gonna do fifty or a hundred books
they get an automatic entry and we'll be
in the book and then get a special call
with you India to make sure the to make
sure that the question is on points so
appreciate all the support Big Ups to
everybody on Facebook who's tagging
people in the comments that means the
world to me because you're trying to
pass on the show glad I ran out of the
courtroom to bring you episode 114 of
the askgaryvee show and i felt tight
with the questions today question of the
day have you ever done jury duty and if
you have tell me your story you keep
asking questions I'll keep answering
them
podcast peeps I know you weren't
expecting a show today 114 it's about to
come at you it's hot ah yeah it's hot
India
give me the podcast keep that lab to you
let's go
yeah
[Music]